yeah there we go hey guys we're doing a
sneak peek little preview and by we I
mean I am ignore the bro tank and the
weird necklace it'll make sense when the
the tour is actually here we have a lot
of costume changes right now we're
getting the VIP merch boxes of really
Amy and Catherine or the heroes here
they've been doing it themselves and
it's just it's super cool you want to
give them a sneak peek what's what's
just pull out one thing Oh actually yeah
we don't show what's inside him but um
they're little tiny Buxton backpacks
teaser for the VIP packages that we did
so these are gonna be handed out to
everybody that got one of those
we just finished a full run of the show
I was very sweaty
I finally cooled down a bit it was
horrible I I actually I took two advil
before but I didn't have any water so I
better swallow him dry and then I the
whole show I thought I was gonna puke
thank you Sam
but the shows were physical it's it's
really good I'm gonna I'm gonna give you
a little little little sliver of speak I
just want to start up here thank you
guys for true heroes and doing this work
while we were we were having fun on
stage so really cool knowing all these
there's so many back fix they go all the
way up they go all the way up that way
20400 backpacks Amy can gather never
touched each and every one of those Oh
Jeremiah you want to be on stream sure
is Jeremiah he's been helping us with
sound that's what this microphone is all
about if you want to tell them anything
about this it's interesting so you can
hear him over the music and the rants of
the other fools yeah the other fools
over there yeah
allison allison is part of right-angle
who's been organizing this whole deal
yeah it's ready just two more days
wait not counting today three are we
counting today three kinda day three
Wednesday yeah almost there we got we
got the show pretty much down let me let
me walk you through that way I'm gonna
go that way just because like I don't
want to show you too much behind the
scenes but I'll show you the theater and
whatnot and then I'll walk you by a
sneak peek little area and it would be
pretty cool so don't tell anyone about
the stream I'm probably gonna deleted
afterwards but just be very hush-hush
about it the theater we're in right now
it's not in afeard we're gonna be
performing in um it's gonna be dark in
here but obviously you know you'll be
able to see a little bit of it but this
is the theater it's very empty right now
because we rented out this theater just
to do our test
in and you can see the stage over there
that we got set up but this one was
chosen because it's going to be close
enough to what we need and it'll be good
I'm still out of breath but we're
getting there so I'm gonna walk you down
we got our little booth up here they're
doing some prep we're gonna do another
run real soon
yeah you won't say a thing I'm sure you
won't expert gaming yeah absolutely you
want yeah and I know a lot of people are
bummed that they weren't able to make it
to this show obviously this initial one
that's why we're doing so much rehearsal
because we were building the show in the
first place because the show isn't like
a typical show that you've seen other
youtubers do I'm not like bragging when
I say that I'm literally saying that
it's what this is so this is Ryan and
this is swanee they are in charge of
making this whole deal it's a little
dark but they are the brains behind the
entire operation and they put this whole
thing together I'm not gonna show them
pretty much anything
oh look their face it's very spooky show
yeah it's a little spooky it could be a
little spooky
ignore the spinning wheel up there
that'll make sense if you get to the
show but I just want to say thank you
guys so much for being a part of this
we're gonna be running in how long
20 minutes we're gonna be back on stage
and doing another full run so I'm taking
you onto the stage right now we're gonna
go behind the scenes a little bit but
not too much that's okay
so we got this big this big screen up
here there's nothing on it right now but
I'm gonna take you around back and
you'll probably see some things in the
background we got a ton of costume
changes and we got a ton of things like
that and that's why the schedule has
been wonky a little bit so ignore all
the stuff that you're seeing in the
background it'll make sense if you come
to the show this this this is our
projector I like I don't show you any of
the costumes or but I'll show you
like the technical aspect of it because
that's what fascinates me this this
little box here is a rear projecting for
that huge screen that cost fifty
thousand dollars we did not pay fifty
thousand dollars for that that is a
rental so everyone is like it is super
super protected with these like boxes
that were boxing in and because nobody
can touch it when we're running around
back here doing costume changes it is so
expensive it is so insanely expensive so
it is the most delicate piece of
equipment here besides me of course we
got the various costume changes draped
here I'm not gonna show you too much of
that just for secret safe for secret EQ
P key secret safe so I did want to talk
about the show in general for anyone
that is coming to the show how many
people are coming out to the show hi Jon
Chee hi Linus I don't know why hi Julia
oh you're not coming to the show okay
that's cool yeah it's completely sold
out right now um it is unfortunately but
we are gonna be doing another run in the
fall oh look look it's the gang hey guys
is the crew here we're resting up yeah
we're live yeah we don't have hair and
makeup for the show we couldn't afford
that we don't have hair would you say
you made that up on your own I didn't
say anything about that one but anyway
this is a little party room did you know
that YouTube live can do a dance party
right then and there never
yeah it's a party up in the green room
yeah it's pretty cool right yeah not bad
yes
so there's uh let me turn it on normal
so you don't get a seizure there
we got Wade here Bob Tyler Evan he will
whole gangs here for some reason swanee
our our director he always calls Ethan
Evan I don't know why okay it doesn't
make any sense so anyway uh so we're
just gearing up to go again on the show
but I wanted to mention during the show
like I said this is not a typical show
this is for anybody that is going to the
show there's not a typical normal show
that you've seen before we can't take
gifts we can't take gifts there are no
breaks during the show there will be
audience members pulled up during the
show like throughout the show there'll
be a lot of them but we can't take
selfies when you do that because it is
literally a show we have set points we
have lights we have staging see that
knee brace is because swanee broke him
in half and beat with sticks and I want
to reiterate this is not because we're
ungrateful we are we have a tour bus
with like very limited space so we
actually we get a coffin yeah we get
coffin so we're gonna be sleeping in
coffins as we travel so we actually
won't be able to have anything but we
just wanted to let you guys know that we
are super excited for this show the
shows come together a lot better than I
could've ever yeah even as super excited
we're all excited like I just can't wait
for all of this to be to be in front of
you guys it's gonna be two days two days
two days
two dicks two dicks until with it that's
the whole show just nothing you're
welcome our Lars - Nick show or balls -
Nick's one vagina who will win who knows
nobody knows one Episode one part of the
show spoil this is one part of the show
I get practically naked on stage like
that's a little bonus for you guys
forget to put on a costume underneath my
normal costume that I take off and I'm
suddenly naked for some reason so
exactly so after that Bob throws my
pants in my eyes you Evan throws my
pants for the bit like you'll see what
we mean it's really not super hard core
porn yeah so we get super close to each
other and like the thought crossed my
mind to kiss yeah but I mean I didn't do
it so it's just it was what is there
what we're going five minutes that is
I've been counting a time are you you
accelerated there all right so uh this
this has been really cool yeah probably
I'm not even in my costume yet okay so
we gotta go um thank you everybody so
much for joining us if you're coming out
to the show I can't wait to show it to
you guys it's gonna be super cool up
until then we're gonna keep practicing
we'll make a good free unless it's bad
and then we'll all up sound good
all right bye guys we gotta get our
costumes